here with reaction author of the Giant
awakes and that's retired lieutenant
colonel Oliver North is with us so he
warns this is the worst crisis since the
Cuban Missile Crisis warns of nuclear
Armageddon his words not mine and his
response is to go to the beach and go on
vacation and take off instead of headed
to The Situation Room why do I have a
problem with that colonel
well we ought I'll have to have a
problem with it I mean there's no doubt
that this President is significantly
compromised both mentally and perhaps
even ethically because of what his son
may have done or didn't do with the
Communist Chinese and so physically
mentally and morally these are very
compromised commander-in-chief now
here's what's happening behind the
scenes first of all it's stunning to me
that a strategic Target like the Kirch
Bridge could be so poorly defended or
protected by the Russians Putin's
response they called it a a bridge
attack a terrorism event well this
morning that 80 plus ballistic missiles
aimed at civilian targets all across the
country it was time to catch people
going to work in the morning notably
Putin was either in or had just come
from an emergency meeting with his
version of the National Security Council
now some in the U.S and NATO
intelligence Services felt that Putin
might have called his National Security
advisors in the session to get their
concurrence for using the Kirch Bridge
attack as a proper vacation for using
attack nuke unkiev now Biden's response
to condemn the Russian attack on
Ukrainian civilians in the strongest
possible terms he says he's talked to
zielinski and promised and I'm quoting
now we are with you no matter how long
it takes and whatever you need so here's
what zielinski needs and he's not
getting from the Americans they need the
ability to knock down Russian rockets
and missiles even though the number
that's available to Putin right now is
considerably reduced because of all that
he's been doing against civilians ever
since the 24th of February people are
talking about the U.S providing
anti-missile defenses like the U.S
Patriot in a missile defense system or
the Israeli Iron Dome defenses now you
remember U.S deployed Patriot batteries
with U.S troops to Saudi Arabia when
their cities and refineries were under
attack from Iranians supported rebels in
Yemen not likely going to happen here
Biden is so there's no boots on the
ground no U.S boots on the ground and
training on Patriot is far more
complicated than the man pad training
that has worked so well in the earlier
phases of this war and the Israeli Iron
Dome would be near perfect for
protecting against Russian missiles but
the Israelis and the Russians are
cooperating with each other to reign in
Hezbollah and the Islamic revolutionary
guard Corps being delivered delivered
yes against Israel through Iraq and
Syria okay so he clearly is not doing as
well as he thought he would do I think
he thought that this would be a cakewalk
uh he's been embarrassed on the world
stage he now is targeting civilians
which by the way he's been doing from
early on clearly he's become isolated
and paranoid people around him seem to
be disappearing on a daily basis uh if
he's willing to
Target civilians the way he is in in
such a brutal fashion uh is it likely to
assume that he'd be capable of using a
tactical nuclear weapon as he says he
might
Sean I don't believe he can okay first
of all why not about their nuclear
program because in 19 well because in
1991 we had a lot of our scientists
helping the U.N redistribute the weapons
and get them out of places like Ukraine
second he's got he's got a very serious
problem of keeping in his own tent the
people whose sons are now fighting this
war and we're drawing down on our own
War stocks to meet the needs of what the
ukrainians want the bottom line of it is
I don't think that Putin can be sure of
being able to convince somebody
downrange to push the button we know
that their pal codes the permission of
accident links are very much like ours
because all the spies that they had
working in our nuclear program since
World War II the bottom line of it is I
don't think and I think he knows he
cannot convince people to push the
button turn the key or enter the codes
he knows that because he's had so many
defectors from his own cause over a
million Russians have fled Russia
because of what they're doing in UK
crane Putin's in trouble Putin may not
survive the experience Putin is taken
out by his best friends I said from the
beginning I'm hoping that there's some
Russian high-ranking people around him
that might know what the right thing to
do is and take care of it for the world
I believe he's capable of it let's see I
pray I'm wrong Colonel uh safe home good
to see you my friend thank you hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else